welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody an interesting Court battles
underway in Tennessee following a
shooting in March at a Christian school
in Nashville multiple groups want a
judge to decide if some of the shooter's
writing should become public Audrey Hale
opened fire inside the Covenant School
killing three children and three adults
the Metro National Police Department
denied open records requests for
writings left behind by the shooter who
was killed by police now the National
Police Association and Tennessee
Firearms Association are suing the
police the groups say there could be
information in the writings that could
benefit Public Safety but opponents
including the school and many parents of
students there point out that copycats
could be inspired by what this shooter
wrote down well now it's up to a judge
to decide if the documents which include
a journal and suicide note should be
released so Mike does the judge only
have two choices here release it all or
release none of it no the judge can
actually go down the middle I believe in
this instance is where he could do it
where he retracts certain parts that he
think it could be prejudicial or harmful
so give a retracted release until a
further decision it's a very difficult
decision because the safety of people
are at risk but once it becomes a
criminal investigation at some point in
time that becomes public records in
preparation for defense you know what's
interesting and Brian as I mentioned
many of the parents the Covenant School
growing movement they don't want the
notes released and I think in a day and
age where we keep seeing school
shootings and mass shootings there's a
legitimate argument that you don't want
to invite copycats because sometimes
these shooters are looking at past
shootings for inspiration so could they
win their case here and not get it
released I mean Jesse I think it's more
than a strong argument I I think we have
the actual writings of the Parkland
school shooter and so I think the
argument to say that these writings
should be released so we can learn more
from them is 100 valid but I think as
Mike said the judge can kind of split
down the middle and say okay but you
these gun right lobbyists don't need the
the information have you ever used this
information to try to cut back on these
school shootings has anyone ever used
this information to do so so why this
one in particular and if he does end up
doing as Mike said kind of going down
the middle okay give it to the people
who are researching ways to stop this
and then rest of the public don't need
it because I do think especially when
you look at things like the Parkland
school shooting and others who drew
swaps because on their on their clothing
and promoted other shootings try to draw
attention to themselves we see as you
said that there are many copycats and I
think the dangerous far out see the
benefits in this situation okay we will
see what the judge ultimately rules well
another big story making headlines right
now police in Rhode Island arrested A
city councilman charging him with drug
possession when an officer approached
Matthew Riley's car around noon on
Monday Riley was passed out with a crack
pipe and lighter in his hand body cam
footage captured the moment that the
officer realized that the man in front
of him was an attorney and city council
member
uh
no way dude really yes yes I was just
taking I was just on my way back from
Court
bro
well Russell's gonna come check you out
man I can't let you go you were
literally choking in your sleep somebody
flagged me down about it oh sleep apnea
I'm sorry well and then you have a crack
pipe in your hands so it's like
wait sorry listen I I have a body camera
obviously yeah I think I have it's
recorded you know that and what I've
observed is on camera so I can't pretend
I didn't you know so a restaurant's
gonna come here and if they're going to
check you out you know as far as I know
there's no drugs anywhere so I know you
know so there's not a criminal
investigation there's more health or
well-being check type thank you
um
but uh yeah I obviously have to document
it you know
you can have that back thank you
still will be no rest what there will be
no rest no
um is there any are there any drugs in
the car or anything like that no no
nothing all right
how long have you had this problem man
it was a it was a relapse I've been
clean for 13 years
all right
I just went through a really really bad
divorce everything okay
um
uh do you know if any of that was laced
with fentanyl or anything because you
were out out and like looked like you
were choking really yeah that's why
someone literally sprinted and flagged
me down because I thought you were
having a heart attack or choking I no
not that I know
and guess what the drugs did test
positive for crack cocaine and Fentanyl
and Riley did end up getting arrested he
has since resigned his position on the
city council and has entered a drug
treatment program
[Music]
and we're finishing Today's Show Out in
Michigan where the parents of the Oxford
High School shooter are fighting to stay
out of a courtroom on involuntary
manslaughter charges the shooter entered
a guilty plea to murder and terrorism
charges last October after killing four
people and injuring seven others in
November of 2021. prosecutors accused
the shooter's parents Jennifer and James
crumbly of ignoring several warning
signs shown by their son prior to the
attack examples include the crumblies
gifting their son the murder weapon for
Christmas and dismissing concerns from
school administrators about his behavior
the decision to send his parents to
trial made it to the Michigan appeals
court but appeals judges ultimately
sided with the prosecution letting the
shooter's parents go to trial on four
counts each of involuntary manslaughter
now the crumbly's defense team is trying
to take the case to the Michigan Supreme
Court and away from a criminal trial in
Thursday's filing they called the
Appellate decision quote clearly
erroneous saying it will cause
injustices and conflicts within the
Michigan court system it's unclear if
the Michigan Supreme Court will hear the
case but here's a portion of the
Appellate hearing that could be rehashed
in a second set of arguments
James crumbly had no knowledge of what
EC was planning he was called over to
the school that day was me he was he
acknowledged then
he had knowledge that there was a
drawing but had no knowledge of what EC
was planning to do that day or at any
other point
certainly a warning signal wouldn't you
say
it could be a warning sign that EC may
have been troubled or may have been
having certain thoughts but not a
morning sign that he was going to kill
for other people
morning
go ahead sorry warning sign that maybe
he had access to a gun
James crumbly did not know that EC had
access to that firearm he bought him the
gun
well and the first thing he did when he
heard about the school shooting was go
back home to see if the gun was there
so certainly was on the top of his head
the school district or the personnel
there equally is culpable so as the
parents as Miss Smith said I would I
would push back on that and say no first
I would disagree that they had the same
level of knowledge these parents knew
more such as he was gifted that gun days
earlier that it was considered his yeah
having a Gun there's nothing illegal for
parents buying a gun for their children
there's not but it is School District
even said it's a it's a fine hobby it is
don't bring it to school it is you also
charged EC as an adult
should that factor in you consider him
as an adult the white or the Oakland
County prosecutor's office the state
considers him an adult
should that factor in our decision here
no he's not he's not a child you're
calling him an adult
I love listening to the judges play
Devil's advocates for both sides but if
focusing on the crumblies for a second
here Mike do you think there were any
additional arguments that they should
have made in the appeals court that
would have helped them and maybe they
need to consider moving forward
that's a tough question because this
this case has so much
unclear and new kind of issues to it and
it really moved like you said about that
judge that judge really gave the vibe
that his first time in the courtroom was
as a real lawyer because he asked very
fair and open questions that showed he
wasn't really
favoring one side or another so I think
this is going to be a case it's really
going to see how it unfolds during the
appeal process because it's a very
unusual issue well Brian let's break
this down so hearing both arguments and
hearing Mike had to say do you think
that the state supreme court judge
should ultimately take on the case
because I'll give you my perspective
real quick I think this is going to have
ramifications not just for the state of
Michigan but for the rest of the country
this is going to be very important and
and maybe would set a precedent moving
forward about the liability of parents
who need to take a second look and not
facilitate their children having weapons
and facilitate these kind of school
shootings this may be a wake-up call for
parents moving forward not just charging
the crumblies but if this actually goes
to trial and they're convicted so let me
ask you again do you think based on
everything her we heard that the state
supreme court judge should take on the
case what I think the state supreme
court will do and and probably should do
is wait for the Appellate course
decision Supreme Court's take on cases
for a number of reasons the two largest
ones I think are if the lower court got
it wrong and they want to correct a
mistake or if they want to establish a
bright line rule I'm not sure whether or
not the Appellate Court got it wrong
from the questions and the way they're
peppering both sides I think they did
get it right I think uh they should be
going towards prosecution and certain
factors can lend towards involuntary
manslaughter and not but I do think the
state supreme court could step in and
create that bright line rule saying
these factors can lead a parent to being
charged with this crime and these
factors can disqualify them because I
think not only for the state of Michigan
but for the entire United States a
bright line would be very helpful
you might be right we will see Brian
Mike thank you both so much everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on Long
crime daily we're going to see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America
foreign